george foreman bonsoir donc on va
raconter votre fabuleuse histoire la
légende de foreman une vie
extraordinaire vous êtes né le 10
janvier 1949 moi je suis né le 6 janvier
donc on n'est pas loin 49 la même année
on a le même âge là quatre jours quatre
jours d'intervalle tous les deux alors
vous êtes né à houston 6 et le nouveau
copain vous vous êtes fait houston texas
dans le quartier le plus chaud de la
ville qui s'appelle travis county et dès
votre plus jeune âge george foreman vous
êtes un teigneux 1 dès votre plus jeune
âge on vous sentez que vous êtes né pour
vous battre un à l'école vous tapiez sur
les les autres élèves
non pas comme un copain dont les ennemis
alors voilà au départ vous êtes un
boxeur amateur niveau moyen mais votre
rage de cogner va vous ouvrir la voie
royale jusqu'au titre olympique
catégorie lourds aux jeux olympiques de
mexico en 68 vous avez 19 ans et vous
ont dégagé en deux rands le russe
lyonnaise chez poulies soit si votre
première grande victoire donc ensuite
vous enchaînez le même type de combat
c'est à dire en de rands chaos ensuite
21 des 30 cet adversaire que vous allez
affronter avant jawf loisirs auront la
même destinée et le 22 janvier 73 et 24
ans vous combattez pour le titre mondial
des lourds à kingston et vous affrontez
le célèbre joe choisir résultats chaos
comme les autres dès la deuxième reprise
un grand puncheur de toute l'histoire de
la boxe je fais un deuxième échange
franc
et lui il était
jadis avaient péché
alors voilà pareil pour ken norton
non plus tard et en octobre 74 a lieu le
combat du siècle
le combat du siècle george foreman
contre mohammad ali organisé e vous
accueillir à la demande de ali parce que
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que mohammad
ali avait été déchu de son titre en 67
qui de champion du monde parce qu'il
s'était converti à l'islam et il avait
refusé de prendre les armes contre de
viet congs ouais il avait dit je n'ai
rien contre les viet congs aucun ne m'a
jamais traité de sale [ __ ] donc il
n'avait pas envie d'aller se battre
contre voilà alors vous êtes reçu à
l'époque mohamed ali et vous par le
président mobutu et se presse à kinshasa
le monde entier quoi y avait déjà me
braun il avait norman mailer qui en a
fait un bouquin enfin tout le monde est
là le fils et le film when we were kings
beau documentaire jamais vu sur le sport
alors à ce moment là vous êtes blessé
une blessure vous obligez reporter le
match de deux mois qu'elle était la
blessure dont vous souffriez à l'époque
avant le combat je me suis coupé
accidentellement
entraîné la fed bien dire c'était une
cicatrice qui a pris un certain temps ah
ouais d'accord alors un mois s'observer
à se défier à s'insulter avec mohamed
ali donc une pression psychologique qui
monte très fort et le 30 octobre 74 60
mille irois sont en stade olympique est
écrit tous à libos my alibo my ce qui
veut dire avis tu le
fais tu es pauvre non
moi je savais que j'allais chez lui je
n'étais pas trop inquiet il faut pas
aller boire et modèles oui c'est moi qui
vais le tuer
il faut quand même avoir une sacrée de
force de caractère pour arriver comme ça
devant soixante mille personnes qui de
toute évidence veulent la victoire de
votre adversaire
sommes une masse souveraine enfin
j'étais en retour tuner tout un défilé
de cap d'ail à main je me faisais avait
joué dans les rues mais ça m'est égal
parce que je savais que c'était moi qui
allais l'emporterait alors effectivement
le peuple zaïrois préféré mohamed ali
parce qu'ils avaient une conscience
politique parce qu'ils défendent elle
est noire il avait voulu que le combat
ait lieu en afrique
vous vous étiez largement favori bien
entendu mais les gens vous étiez un
petit peu le bad boy vous par rapport à
mohammad ali vous étiez le mec qui
étaient là pour l'argent quoi d'une
certaine façon dont
j'ai uniquement pour l'argent et pour
assainir le soin mohamed ouais alors un
film a été tourné un documentaire
magnifique a été tourné sur ce combat et
les jours qui l'ont précédé et suivi il
s'appelle when we were kings
que mr
[Applaudissements]
op
je pouvais beaucoup
on a cru
voilà wayne minaar qu'ils s'appellent
cargo à la 8e reprise et lorsque sonne
le gong à la fin du compte de l' arbitre
le tonnerre se met à gronder sur
kinshasa la pluie se met à ruisseler sur
la ville et mohamed ali fait le mariole
et il fait le tour comme ça du ring en
disant je vous avais bien dit qu'il
savait pas encaisser et vous vous dites
c'est comme si ali avait tué ma vie
c'est dire que quand on était champion
du monde et qu'on perd son titre on a
l'impression d'avoir perdu sa team a
conclu un accord en journée et le roi le
non épurée du tout c'était pas très
agréable qu'elle avait fait après le
match
as france je suis allé me revue me
calmer chez moi il faut j'étais quand
même un peu crevé à la marge même si je
m'étais fait agresser j'avais gagné de
l'argent mais je me suis quand même tapé
dessus ouais alors là vous péter les
plombs je crois que je sais pas si le
traducteur va y arriver mais enfin vous
péter les plombs carrément dans les 30
jours suivant vous vous tapez 30 femmes
1 c'est à dire que vous devenez comme
celle-là vous dépensez dans cette
période 3 millions de dollars c'est à
dire que vraiment vous vous exploser
complètement vous achetez des grosses
bagnoles c'est dire que dans chaque
ville où vous allez après aux états unis
vous achetez des énormes voiture enfin
vous êtes devenu un peu fou d'une
certaine façon non
mais t'es cette information c'est bien
que vous ne disiez aussi
non c'est vrai vous achetez une grosse
voiture par ville vous venez
c'est à dire que j'essaie de compenser
un point s'était fait quand on a perdu
un titre aussi précieux que champion du
monde dans décès de compenser s'harnache
on était bien sûr mais ça marche pas non
alors vous achetez même un lion est un
tigre pour votre ranch voilà c'était
vraiment enfin tout le pognon il est
passé quoi 15 millions de francs c'est
un petit peu on peut dire une sorte de
déchéance vous refusez à mohamed ali sa
revanche en 77 vous remonter sur le ring
vous mettez quand même une tannée
à jo phrase here mais la même année
lors d'un match perdu vous voyez du sang
qui coule sur votre poitrine et là vous
êtes persuadé que vous allez mourir vous
voyez la mort en face au vide ça y est
j'y suis et à ce moment là vous entendez
une voix divine
je cherchais la satisfaction que
j'allais chercher à travers la boxe et 7
nuits en 67 j'ai eu cette vision j'avais
gens semblent je serai tout partout
autour de moi cette divinité alors
comment j'étais tout seul et je n'étais
pas religieux et ce soir là je me suis
dit un peu m'importe si la mort est là
je crois que dieu existe et j'ai été
tirée d'une énorme assassins et j'ai
commencé à avoir ce sang coulait j'ai
commencé à prier bible jésus et la
mémoire tout le monde croit que j'étais
fou moi même commencé par bon et puis
depuis ce jour je n'en ai que faire le
total de raconter cette histoire comment
j'ai trouvé la paix la sérénité que je
cherchais je détestais mohamed ali le
reste du monde mais en fait je suis
parti avec l'amour pour mon prochain
c'est ça c'est dire qu'à un moment vous
dit j'étais comme mort et j'ai eu le
sentiment que jésus est rentré dans mon
corps
c'est exactement ça c'était cette vision
peut maintenant j'étais dans la laure
jean marc récupérer après cette vision
de mort qui avaient envahi c'est là que
ma vie a changé ouais alors ce sera
votre chemin de damas ça sera le début
de votre rédemption et vous devenez
pasteur fait une histoire absolument
extraordinaire comment ce grand boxeur
devient pasteur est désormais quand vous
allez monter sur le ring george foreman
ce sera pour aider des jeunes
défavorisés
en disant j'ai arrêté de boxer sa
maîtresse est probable que 77 87 je n'ai
pas fermé le point une seule fois
concentré ma vie sur cette activité de
le passer au mariage et il manquait
d'argent a travaillé avec la jeune donc
il fallait que je à mobiliser des
capitaux je savais que coûte pour le
faire il fallait que je redevienne
champion du monde et je souhaite tout
d'abord mais cette fois là j'étais en
auvergne vous dire que je ne frappais
jamais avec colère ouais alors vous avez
suivi un régime draconien à ce moment là
c'est à dire que vous vous êtes monté
jusqu'à 102 kg c'est ça mais je vous
prie petit lui
80 est
lui élu
john boorman il a pesé jusqu'à 140 kg 1
c'est énorme et là vous avez fait un
régime draconien à 42 ans
vous vous donnez un mal de chien vous
fait du jogging qu'est ce que vous avez
fait pour perdre ce poids parce qu'à
l'époque n'est pas encore le régime de
karl lagerfeld
a big bang que j'ai commencé à
manger mieux que sortira effectivement
j'ai fait des kilomètres
par jour il fallait que je redevienne
champion poids lourd alors vous battez
contre holyfield à l'époque des cartes 2
en 1 vous perdez met au point et il faut
dire que lee fields à l'époque était
quand même champion du monde est alors
choses extraordinaires à 45 ans vous
redevenez champion du monde à 45 ans
contre michael moore voilà
c'était très important pour la
reconquérir ce titre je me suis dit que
lorsque au
septième round on m'avait demandé au
gadjo alors je vais et était morte
georges ou pas et j'avais plus rien en
moi
plus tard comme si c'était tout ce que
j'avais en moi et j'ai dit non il me
reste encore beaucoup obtenez george
foreman
[Musique]
voilà dix ans forman c'est la plus
grande distinction
la plus grande distinction qu'on peut
recevoir dans cette émission c'est le
triomphe romain s'est réservé à
quelques-uns il faut avoir été champion
du monde de bolt je préfère le dire
alors désormais vous êtes pasteur boxeur
et vous représentez un produit qui
marche très très bien qui s'appelle le
tshirt forman grill on y trouve une idée
ça ça vous plairait il a trouvé l'idée
très simple c'est de mettre un grill
incliné ou km comme ça qui fait que la
grèce school et tu manges pas de graisse
et vous vous êtes devenu le sait bien
comme idée géniale oui il est plus
simple vous allez mes yeux voilà et donc
ça marche très très bien dans le monde
entier vous êtes désormais donc le le
représentant de de ce produit dans le
monde sait ça
veut dire que j'ai c'est maintenant
d'être champion du monde des poids
lourds mais à 55 ans je ferai un nouveau
come back en meilleure forme et
j'ai ce crime
comme on respire en forme quel que soit
votre âge dépend de ce qu'on recherche
et cette ville de vous permet de rester
jeune et voilà est ce que vous
connaissez ou essence george foreman
m
alors comme je suis un garçon
extrêmement courageux je vais faire
l'interview suicide
josh forman quand vous redevenez
champion du monde à 45 ans le combat
était truquée non
ok ok ok
jazz forman vous croyez qu'on se
souviendra de vous comme champion du pot
tout comme marchande grill
non à don't want to fuck you and just
ask
djoman quand vous êtes devenu pasteur
c'était pour garder l'argent de la quête
on arrête
les corrections de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous il m'était impossible
eux